even the MCU strongest and most
charismatic villains have weak spots of
their own through which the heroes wind
up gaining the upper hand and saving the
day from Iron Monger to kill monger here
are the biggest weaknesses of these MCU
bad guys the Marvel Cinematic Universe
got its start in 2008 with Iron Man
which introduced the world to Robert
Downey jr. as Tony Stark and laid the
groundwork for the next 10 years of
genre-defining superhero movies as
iconic as the first Iron Man film is
however we wouldn't blame you for
forgetting about Obadiah Stane the
vicious opponent who inadvertently
pushed Tony to transform from a
brilliant but selfish arms dealer into a
world saving self-sacrificing hero stain
was an old friend of Howard Stark Tony's
father and served as CEO of Stark
Industries after Howard's death until
Tony was able to take over despite his
fatherly demeanor stain coveted Tony's
role as the man in charge and he wound
up throwing in his lot with the 10 rings
in an effort to get Tony out of the
picture and regain control of the
company stain simply was not content to
beat Tony's mentor and second-in-command
especially when Tony's conscience
started cutting into Stark Industries
bottom line he hoped to seize back the
company from its idealistic CEO and he
created the Iron Monger suit to help him
do just that
unfortunately for stain the greed that
motivated him to steal a company was
also what led to his ultimate demise not
only did he pause to gloat rather than
finishing Tony off his rush to build his
own Iron Man suit without Tony's
brilliance backing it up left him with a
powerful but crucially flawed design
how'd you saw the icing problem
I see problem look into it that
combination of arrogance and greed along
with an unfortunate choice to open up
his Armour to brag face to face put a
quick end to stains career as a super
villain it's no secret that the children
of Odin could use quite a bit of family
therapy although each of them seems to
struggle with a different issue the all
fathers youngest son Loki wrestles with
a godly inferiority complex that pit him
against his family and would come to
threaten not just the world but the
entire universe even before he learned
that he was actually the biological son
of the frost giant King laughy Loki felt
like he could never get out of his
brother Thor's shadow so I locked up
here until you might have you something
why'd you twist my work after learning
the truth of his origins Loki's
insecurity kicked into overdrive he
compensated by attempting to get rid of
his brother entirely so that he wouldn't
have to compete with him anymore
even though Thor himself never saw Loki
as anything but a beloved brother that
anger even drove him to drop into the
vast emptiness of space rather than
accept his brothers mercy after his
first defeat when Loki returned in the
Avengers it was as a puppet of Thanos
throwing in with the universe's most
evil villain in an effort to prove
himself superior to his brother even
then the greatest opponent Loki faced
was his own self-doubt well self-doubt
and the Hulk over and over he attempted
to prove that he was worthy of something
he already had the love and respect of
his adopted family at first he acted out
in unhealthy and harmful ways in an
attempt to convince both his relatives
and himself that he didn't need anything
from them even though he obviously
yearned for their approval eventually as
he learned to accept that Thor had
always loved him just the way he was he
was able to work productively alongside
his brother instead of feeling
threatened by him just in time to be
taken out by Thanos in front of the
brother with whom he just made peace
better late than never as a literal
robot it's unsurprising that the
genocide --all Ultron adhered pretty
stringently to rules of his own making
however his inability to compromise or
bend his rigid views is what ultimately
led to his downfall in Avengers age of
Ultron while that and the Hulk these bad
guys don't really do so well with him
huh a product of Tony Stark's
peacekeeping program which was
subsequently beefed up by the mine stone
Ultron's core objective was to protect
the Earth from future threats
unfortunately for everyone after mulling
over his mission for a while Ultron
determined that the biggest threat to
earth was in fact humans and he said
about attempting to eradicate them the
fixed mindset that sent Ultron on his
destructive path was also what caused
his end even after meeting opposition
from the vision an artificial beam
created the same way Ultron couldn't be
reasoned with if Ultron had been able to
change his mind perhaps the Avengers
would have found a way to allow him to
exist as it was Ultron single-mindedness
paved the way for his complete
annihilation just like all of his
robotic creations superhero movies might
be popular but they tend to be a hard
sell when it comes to critical
acknowledgment every now and then though
one manages to break through as an
awards contender because it's simply too
compelling to ignore this was the case
with Black Panther and a big part of
that film success was thanks to its
villain Erik kill monger
unlike most Marvel movies which tend to
open with the heroes origin story
Black Panther started with kill muggers
and from the moment we saw him as a
child in that opening scene he was
incredibly sympathetic in fact as the
film progressed the moviegoers in the
audience and even some of the film's
good guys had to admit that kill monger
was making a few good points these items
on for sale how do you think your
ancestors got these you think they paid
a fair price what are they taking my
baby cook everything else
T'Challa himself conceded that his
father to Chaka was wrong about
wakanda's policy of isolation and that
abandoning young Erik had been a mistake
yet rather than cultivate the favor of
the people already inclined to agree
with him kill monger wound up pushing
them away with his uncompromising
extremist views while adopting a more
measured approach could have won him
allies with in Wakanda including
possibly even T'Challa Hill mongers plan
was to stoked civil uprisings by
flooding the world with wakandan weapons
his all-or-nothing approach to achieving
his vision meant that rather than
finding an ally in the king of Wakanda
he found an opponent and the to wound up
battling to the death Loki spent his
entire cinematic lifetime struggling to
dig out from under a hefty pile of
self-doubt and prove his worthiness to
his father his brother and most of all
himself his older sister hella had the
opposite problem in thor ragnarok she
was so convinced that she should be
ruling over
scarf that she thought all she'd have to
do was show up and people would fall in
line behind their beloved new Queen
granted she was a formidable opponent as
evidenced by her ability to take out the
Warriors three and the armies of asgaard
single-handedly still marching through
the streets taking out beloved
second-string marvel characters and
sending all the other ass Guardians into
hiding doesn't really endear you to the
public no matter how cool your giant
wolf is in other words she wasn't
exactly greeted as a liberator and her
entitlement lulled her into thinking
she'd prevails simply because she
thought she should I believe me I would
love for someone else to rule but it
can't be you you're just the worst
Ellis sense of superiority kept her from
winning anyone to her cause with even
her right-hand lieutenant abandoning
ship when he couldn't stomach any more
of her actions she could have relied on
her legitimate claim to the throne to
win over the ass guardians but instead
of working with her brothers she blasted
them into oblivion without even checking
to make sure they were gone for good
leaving herself wide open for them to
team up against her if she had taken the
time to actually interact with the
people of asgaard instead of terrorizing
them or if she'd collaborated with her
brothers instead of opposing them it may
have led to an Asgard that all three of
Odin's children could have lived in
together instead of one that had to be
raised into nothing Carol Danvers faces
a variety of opponents in Captain Marvel
but jaan raghav are the most insidious
he spends most of the film pretending to
be her mentor and Ally but even when
he's being set up as Carol's friend
there are hints of darkness lying
beneath his friendly surface multiple
times he attempts to diminish her power
under the guise of training her accusing
her of being too emotional he pushes her
to hold back rather than develop her
strength and discourages her from
exploring the limits of her powers he
claims this is for her own good to teach
her control but it's really designed to
keep her weak so that he can hold the
power in the relationship gradually as
Carol uncovers the truth of who she is
she begins to realize that yon Ragini
was never meant to help her instead he
was giving her a pair of metaphorical
handcuffs holding her back so that the
Kree can use her for their own purposes
Carol stepping into her own power feels
like a threat to yon rug who wishes to
keep her small so that he can feel big
important and powerful he even goes so
far as trying to win her over with the
approval he's been holding back once she
realizes
truth strip away the superpowers and
it's a story all too familiar for many
women who have been abused by insecure
men yon rocks weakness doesn't have
anything to do with his physical
capabilities but everything to do with
how threatened he feels by a strong
woman it's an attitude that leads him to
getting blasted into a rock because once
Carol figures out what he's doing she
has no tolerance for it anymore there
isn't a single Marvel villain who
doesn't have some degree of hubris in
their character but no one displays this
trait more than Thanos who's planned to
eliminate half of all life in the
universe culminates in Avengers infinity
war and Avengers endgame Thanos is
convinced that what he's doing isn't
just right but necessary and that it's
up to him to set things on a path that
only he's allowed to determine no matter
the cost
granted Thanos is incredibly powerful
and he actually does succeed despite his
arrogance but in viewing himself and his
plan as inevitable Thanos doesn't ever
consider that there may be value in
individual lives teamwork and
self-sacrifice he views the Avengers as
pests to be swatted down rather than
serious threats and it never occurs to
him that some what could be willing to
sacrifice everything to preserve the
live Stannis wants to take the Avengers
fight their battle knowing the odds are
against them which makes them willing to
do whatever they have to in order to
earn their victory they're willing to
sacrifice themselves while Thanos is
only willing to sacrifice others the mad
Titan never even considers that he might
lose which cracks open the door for
exactly that to happen for the first act
of spider-man far from home Quentin Beck
seems like a pretty good guy he's funny
he's charming and he seems like exactly
the sort of smart and nurturing mentor
figure Peter Parker is looking for
unfortunately he's also a con man
nursing a serious grudge against his
former employer Tony Stark and he's
decided that the whole world has to pay
for the wrong that was done to him
to be fair Tony Stark was probably a
pretty terrible boss to work for and
absolutely underestimated the technology
back in his crew used throughout the
film Beck has every right to be mad but
the lengths he goes to in drawing
together a group of similarly wronged ex
employees and hatching a plan to destroy
entire cities in order to usurp Tony's
legacy that goes a little beyond leaving
him a bad review on Glassdoor this
bitterness pushes Mysterio to keep going
way past the time when
should have stopped it leads him to keep
attacking Peter with his drones even
after they start malfunctioning which
ultimately leads to his death check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite MCU characters are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]